i see you literally being hounded to
death and i'm helpless this topic
no that's not harry and meghan but it
is two actors playing them i am the
person who is strong
and gets things right that's right we
have our first look at the upcoming
lifetime movie
harry and megan escaping the palace in
which the sussex's royal exit gets the
tv
movie treatment i can't lose you i can't
lose you
actors jordan dean and sydney morton
take on the famous couple
in what's actually the third film in
lifetime's harry and meghan royal movie
franchise
the two previous movies feature
different pairs of actors in the roles
hi
hey megan hello yeah i'm harry in 2018
harry and megan a royal romance focused
on how the couple fell in love
while 2019's harry and meghan becoming
royal
chronicled their first year of marriage
it's your name
that complicated things what i love
is you now this latest installment will
portray the royal drama that unfolded
over the past year
i see you literally being honed to death
and i'm helpless to stop it
i am the person who is strong and gets
things right
the preview even teases a recreation of
megan and harry's tell-all interview
with oprah winfrey
i can't lose you i can't lose you harry
and megan is keeping the powers
no official release date has been
released yet for the movie
but it will likely premiere this fall
meanwhile the real harry and megan have
been busy with their newborn daughter
lillabet diana mountbatten windsor
the name pays tribute to both queen
elizabeth and princess diana
and as royal expert katie nichol tells
e.t
this choice might represent an olive
branch to the royal family
well i think everyone's hope is that
this little baby is going to be
a rift healer um because this
family division has really gone on for a
very long time now
it's well over a year it's been many
many months
since charles the queen indeed the
cambridges have seen
archie in the flesh and we know that
there have been some
really quite deep problems between harry
and williams
difficulties between harry and his
father and i think it's everyone's
hope that this little baby will will be
a peace offering
in many ways and that she will help to
bring this divided family
back together